what's going on everybody welcome to
another flask with Python tutorial video
in this video what we're gonna be
talking about is a little bit more on
Jinja templating in general so obviously
we already know about logic and
variables and stuff like that but there
is a few other little subtle things that
I find myself needing fairly often with
Jinja so here we go
so first of all I've got in it that pi
open up here I'm gonna come down just
grab a function somewhere if I can find
a decent why don't take this one and I'm
just gonna come right underneath it and
start a new one this one we're gonna
call ginger man Zhu Jemaine and the
template will call ginger templating dot
HTML okay so now we need a ginger
templating dot HTML so let's go ahead
and put it in templates so new file
ginger actually Jinja templating dot
HTML cool now we need to populate this
with some data instead of going through
and writing at all like we did in a
previous tutorial the link to this
text-based tutorial is in the
description head there and you can grab
the starting information for this
template it should look basically just
like this and let's make this a little
bigger previous tutorial luckily we
weren't really doing anything that was
super important HTML wise but it's kind
of hard to see the HTML so how does I
forget to zoom it in I hate to program
with it like that big you know I want it
small anyway so first of all what we
want to do let's grab some variables to
pass through now from the the tutorial
itself I'm just gonna take what we use
there so we're gonna pass the following
data that's too big as well but I want
it so everybody can see nice on the
video but it's hard sometimes anyway so
here's some data we have we have a
regular number 15 then we have a string
15 then we have a
another string that says pythons good
then we have a an apparent list and then
we've got some HTML here okay so that's
the data again you can either write it
out write something similar or just kind
of follow along you don't actually have
to type all this out to get the value
out of the tutorial anyway so we'll just
save that and I am I think we're done
actually with this I'm not sure we're
gonna visit this again so I'm going to
close that and let's go ahead and run a
reload and I don't know if I have this
so let's try it reload I noticed that
before
it's weird on my other server a service
Apache to reload no problems it it
really does refresh everything but
lately on here I've been having trouble
having that actually refresh everything
so I don't know maybe my awesome answer
for everyone wasn't so awesome after all
anyway so here is the URL and that's
Gingerman there and we just don't have
anything here so there's no data there
so now what we want to do is let's start
referencing some of that information
that we passed through how we got to
open up the init file and I didn't pass
it actually through what an amateur
alright ginger man there we go we need
to take data and pass it through so data
equals data all right good to go let's
read let's reload Apache are we still
restarting a patch here no what's
happening okay let's do a reload and see
if that actually works for us although
of course we don't really have anything
to test that but we'll see in a moment
if that worked
so we bring this up and then what we're
gonna do first is like we can just
iterate through the data so we can do
something like this we can say
let's just say for DN data and then
we'll come down here close the for loop
and for and first let's just iterate out
the D I'm immature sometimes
alright so BAM refresh okay so so we at
least have the data and let's instead
let's iterate out per paragraph so it's
like separated nice and pretty
we're refresh again okay cool
so 1515 we can see obviously hTML is not
going to treat each string and any
differently Python is good cool we got
our list here and then we noticed
something pretty interesting is that we
passed the string of HTML and it
actually came through as HTML and let's
say it's just hey there so hey there
you'll see that it actually converted it
to the little special characters so it's
not actually a real character it's a
fake one so so we have that that there
and so the idea here is to talk about
how we can handle for Strings and ins
differently
how we can you'll see what I mean well
how we're gonna fix this statement how
we can iterate through this list and how
we can make that actually HTML so
there's our list we'll just come right
below it let's add a horizontal row and
let's begin programming something else
so the next thing that we'll do is we
say something like this if data 1
so the first if element so this is 0 if
this is the first tooth that was a
string if I have a call right that's my
hope anyway Zuniga man I keep having to
open this right so the or the first
tooth element is actually the second
element which is a string so it's a
string 15 so we can say is if data 1 and
then we can convert it to an int by
doing this int right if you want to
convert something to a string it would
be string notice that it's this little
bar right so just to show you that we
convert it to an int and we're all we're
all fine with that if it is greater than
10 which it should be
let's and if and we'll just we'll just
have it print out true yeah okay now
we'll run this all at the very end
you'll just have to take my word for it
it'll it's gonna work out so next what
we're going to do is we're going to run
a replacement function so let's do so
for data data too so the third element
there I pryzen is leave this open but
that's okay this is the Python is good
string okay I'm just gonna put it over
here on this monitor okay so that is the
python is good string now what we can do
is we can run a replace now some people
are like hmm should we just do like
replace like this no you can't do a dot
replace that would be it's a bar replace
now so bar replace and then we want to
replace good with frickin no it can't be
freaking that's absolutely absurd
frickin awesome exclamation mark okay so
that's a replace function now what we
can do is finally let's do let's add
another horizontal row H for horizontal
roll make some space here then what
we'll do is let's say for Lang in so
here we have a list of languages right
Python Java PHP SQL C++ and there but
it's a string it's not really a Python
list so what we would do in Python is
you would you would split it right so
for example for data let's say for Lang
in data three and then again I ask is it
a dot split or is it a bar split it's
actually a dot split so you probably got
that wrong sorry dot split and it will
be by a comma
and so then we've completely basically
converted that to lists and n4 and then
we'll come over here and P Lang actually
to make this really right I didn't do
this in the write up tutorial but to do
it the right way probably would be
something like this so unordered list
and then it says it'll be list item this
would be the more common way you would
use that okay so we convert it to a list
output it cool so we'll see that when
it's all all said and done and then
finally to display HTML like this you
have you add a little bar safe so so
what we would do is you obviously we're
not gonna need paragraphs there so that
was data the fourth element and then you
do this bar safe okay and that'll
actually allow the HTML to be executed
so let's go ahead and save that again
we'll come over here and let's run it or
refresh hopefully no errors cool oh man
we got way weird that's not an error
we're just stupid but while I'm stupid I
wonder if any but hopefully some of you
guys didn't make the same mistake as me
that's a variable so save that try one
more time oh my goodness
oh my goodness it's too late for me at
the moment and it's raining outside okay
live in Texas it hasn't rained in like I
don't know like eight months and we're
getting a bunch of rain right now and
it's just I don't know how to handle it
I haven't had to mow the yard in eight
months that's how I know how long it
hasn't rained because I'm just the yard
is dead anyway
uh-huh my life so we've got the true
statement came through no problem we did
or replace no problem we converted our
string list into a nice HTML list and we
converted HTML and actually displayed
the HTML now plus does have a built-in
string template
right that you could do but this is for
like short SQL blurbs so like let's say
you've got a database where like for
example if you have something like oh my
gosh evading me WordPress right
everything you enter in WordPress goes
to an SQL database and then it displays
it back on-screen so you've got a lot of
HTML stored in the database well
natively with flask if you read SQL from
a database and go to display it it's
gonna look just like this in flask
because that it reflects considers that
dangerous so you have to opt in
basically and say hey this is okay now
there is a back end option you can
change and you don't have to worry about
it so much and it's like basically the
opposite you would say this data might
not be safe or something but anyway this
is the default so that's how you do it
and a lot of times like if you use like
we had to do safe with our when we use
the charting application that name is
evading me too I'm telling you it's the
rain it's killing me
hi charts there it is that needs it and
basically anything that it's going to
return some HTML that you're gonna pass
through you're gonna need to do that so
this one's probably the most valuable of
everything so far but I've needed to use
all of these so next what we're gonna do
is we're going to talk about macros just
really quick we're gonna basically just
run right off of the docs here so these
are the docs I can't remember if I
showed them in the very beginning again
I'm claiming terrain for this now so you
should definitely check out the docs
from time to time it's just like
bootstrap
right like every time you start a new
project or you sit down to work and
you're trying to figure out how you
might go about doing something so it's a
good idea to check out the docs and by
checking out the docs
I don't mean I don't think anybody else
really means I don't think anybody maybe
the first time someone will sit down and
read literally through the docs but
generally like when I go to visit some
Doc's I just like look at him and I go
like this like all the way through I'm
like looking at comments like I had
never heard of comments until really
recently I did not
how to comment with Jinja and bam got
that figured out and you just got to
scroll on through just kind of trying to
pick up some stuff now anyway moving to
macros this is some good information
here and I think this is like just super
cool so what you can do is you can take
this macro and it's like defining a
function in Python so we're just going
to literally copy and paste from the
docs I'll try to recall or remember to
put the link to the docs in the video I
might forget but you can always just do
Jinja template Docs okay and you can
figure it out also this URL is not too
difficult so we'll come down here and
we'll add another horizontal row or a
quick and we're just gonna copy and
paste this macro the idea is that it's a
macro for any input form so anytime you
want to pop out an input form instead of
having to type all this nonsense you
just simply create the function and but
a boom bada bing
you've got your input form which is
especially useful especially if you're
always classing something the same way
or you know trying to think of some
other good examples but a lot of times
when you have like an input or form
you've got names values and IDs all that
need to be populated so every time
you're just throwing in all this
nonsense where it could be quite a bit
simpler so that's just a quick example
we'll just save that and run that real
quick so there you have it we defined
the function for the input basically
here it's called a macro in Jinja but
think of it like defining a function
so there's your macro we define it and
then we called two instances of it here
so already saving space having it one
thing you might be curious about is
these dashes you notice these little
dashes here now this is just some real
leet Jinja I think I have never seen the
dashes until I looked at ginger
documentation but they're kind of cool
because they actually do help so if we
go and look at although we've got my
crap code but if we go look at the
source code for this
here okay that looks really nice it's
all like kind of stuck together as you
might say and what we can do is get rid
of those little minuses save that and
let's refresh the page it looks the same
but then if we go to the view source
look it's ugly like the source code is
ugly so like when potential employers or
just other programmers go to look at
your source code when you're coding with
flask it can make your source code look
really ugly like it makes you look like
you're an idiot sometimes
and I've always kind of recognized that
but at the same time I just you know
first of all my HTML is a lot of times
pretty ugly but it makes you look worse
than yours so it's almost like a purely
vanity thing to do this but it does help
I think it obviously and if you it is a
serious thing if you're trying to get
you know you know if you're showing off
your projects to a potential employer
and they go to look at your source code
they're like wow this guy is a huge mess
yeah it's not good for you you know they
might not be making the realization of
what's going on in the back end to cut
that like the back end is generating the
HTML wasn't you that wrote that so
anyway that's pretty cool and really the
final thing that I'll show you guys is
logic now we've already been over logic
and we're not going to spend any more
time other than me just saying hey come
to the docs and look at logic because
there are certain things that you have
here that you don't have in Python and
there are some things here that you
don't have in PI or that you have in
Python but you don't have in Jinja and
there's some things that you have in
Jinja to be doing Python so just keep
that in mind Jinja is not like some sort
of Python language for HTML right it's
its own language does its own stuff it
just happens to work really nicely with
Leste and Django and probably some other
frameworks anyway so so you have these
bits of logic that are actually
available to you is in all that sounds
pretty normal and
or not simple stuff then you've got
these operands here converts everything
the strings and concatenates them pretty
useful this is you can call a callable
oh that's really not much different than
Python and this is to get the attribute
literally never needed it but it's there
if you need it and then there's some
more stuff here again I just reiterate
it's always a good idea to just go
through the docs from time to time the
stuff that I'm telling you or stuff that
I find myself using and myself needing
from time to time but you might be
totally different right so your needs
might not be the same needs as mine so
what I say hey I use this a lot so check
this out may not actually apply to you
so anyways definitely check out the
documentation just from time to time
just literally just like scroll through
it and just read the headings and see if
anything sounds interesting to you so
anyway that's it for the basically just
the simple Jinja templating stuff next
up we're going to be talking about
dynamic URLs which are I thought it
would be on this page it probably is I'm
just missing it but they're actually
called converters in flask I'm not quite
sure what the origin of converters was I
want to call it dynamic URLs but anyway
that's we're gonna be talking about the
next tutorial so stay tuned for that if
you have questions comments concerns
whatever on this tutorial feel free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support subscriptions and until next
time